so you're you're telling me your
ultimate ambition is to go to Mars not
the 440 million right but I want money
to build look make sure about three
times as much needed to pay your husband
to go to Miami
oh my Gary help everybody Jesse wasn't
one to go to Mars
I like your honor bit no I'm super happy
Jonathan I think you should document you
should you should literally document
your journey to Mars bro
[Music]
I don't want people imposing old Boehner
I don't want people you know saying now
the grown-ups are here I don't want
people saying that new person created
this dynamic people confused people just
don't know who I am and so I need to
uncuff you in a real way and I need to
start with the people that I think in it
or as close to it potentially as I think
has happened and then chip away and what
is the last piece or seven pieces or
nine pieces like what is it you know I'm
individual basis but like just not as
good as we can be by any stretch of the
imagination compared to what's in here
and here I'm just going to do it now
that's gonna hurt and it's going to be
awesome you know what I mean
sit like you know working out sucks when
you're doing it awesome you know what I
mean then you get to walk up a [ __ ]
wall in one second there's just so much
to do and one of the great ways is
addition by subtraction and one of the
best ways is meritocracy and one of the
best
is comfort and communication there's
these things art riding through I know
how to do them all and I'm just going to
do it better I guess you know we do
better and I don't and that's that like
what I'm basically asking for is what I
do right like everything literally walks
in here starting at a hundred and then
through political behavior they start
leaving or if they're just not good at
their craft I mean it's important it is
important we are back in our ecosystem
but this is a game of the truth of the
truth versus that perceived truth that's
what this conversation I mean it and I
mean it across the board I mean it
because it's just binary either you just
blindly believe that all the intense
right and this is a moment in time and
if it's too long at the moment I'm that
you removal beyond go to Gary and then
I'll get the four one one and I'll go
back out or you don't that's it those
are the models that's it either it's all
good always and forever it is the
greatest oh [ __ ] I don't feel that now
for for rules for Harry that's three
straight weeks you know for James it's
four months oh oh I feel it go in get an
update get your [ __ ] answer clean
simple the answer the answers with
series of answers kick back out that's
what I want and so when you're producing
content because of the search
capabilities because the utilitarian
nature of the content people will post
about food on Instagram and on Pinterest
there's much more to do with it on
Pinterest it has the intent for it to be
deeper and more complex than this is
what I'm eating or this is a good
picture of my sushi you know this you
know and so the utilitarian nature and
the publisher magazine kind of DNA is a
very important thing as you read this
chapter to understand tumblr is actually
Instagram it just bucked up like they
just didn't go mobile either so that was
the big interesting transition post
crush yet even around the thing around
the Thank You economy time if I wrote a
book would have been interesting because
it would have been more about mobile
but I decided to go more up here right
but tumblr was the one that really long
there are enormous amounts of people on
YouTube making millions of dollars a
year
enormous left like real longtail
millions not just hundreds of thousands
in creating video content vlogging
specifically is interesting to me
because I'm very concerned that a lot of
you do not have your talents that you're
not funny that you're not super gorgeous
that you're not athletic what's amazing
about vlogging is it's the documenting
over creating it's the thing that so
many people make fun of the Kardashians
and all the reality stars before them
yet those people have executing on while
you're reading this book they did it on
TV platform YouTube is the number one
network on the mobile device for that
behavior I believe that Facebook will
become a massive video player even by
the time this is fully printed and
distributed I'm aware and ready for
Facebook to be doing more stuff that
looks like YouTube but YouTube is a
monster and if I have one core
recommendation if you just don't know
what to do if you can't figure out if
you want to be the number one authority
about pajamas in America the number one
move you should do is to document your
day with your phone or fancy camera and
put it up daily on YouTube under the
context of a vlog
[Music]
ah
everybody's accounted a nerd shock in
the sense of 240 I asked Gary be shut
okay what's your name is John all right
Jonathan LeClair
I love the man what's your question okay
so we sort of the tweet 17-foot
challenge
try doing that phone book let me just
say one thing let me say one thing
John's an apologist it just has to be
medicine for everybody who might not
notice the reason the 2017 flip
challenge happened was because I was on
The Breakfast Club we were doing our
thing and we said okay give a practical
piece of advice because I'm good or I
didn't fold and feel sad I came up with
one on the spot which was go buy stuff
for the dollar store and thrift stores
sell stuff in your house and now there
are tens of thousands of people selling
stuff I'm getting crazy emails of like
hi I have no money now I have $4,000 cuz
I sold all my clothes that I don't wear
so it's been huge I'm glad you jumped on
it and Thank You Charlamagne for having
me on the show to create that little
micro movement go ahead Jonathan
okay so mid progress on that but it's
going slower than I'd like is when we
made a couple thousand dollars only oh
my god - oh we made a couple thousand
come on bro how much did you have before
zero you don't never problems a lot of
you kids nowadays they want it now
instead of realizing that you just gotta
appreciate the process and I'll say
something about Jonathan I can tell that
him and his homie wanted to be smarter
they said wait a minute
right like I can feel it from him
Jonathan here's what i'ma say if you
want to be the platform that's such a
big game everybody wants to be over and
Airbnb and Amazon and Google right I
don't want to be the classic I want to
still use Amazon for reselling I just
want to get the donation so I don't have
to pay over I know that you want to be a
platform or if you want to be a
collection platform for the inventory so
you can flip it the problem is you have
zero awareness okay you got to be
annoying now you have to be dj khaled
levels of annoying you've got to be like
Sarah Sharla man is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but he's my favorite one absolutely
you got to be a lovable Apple is nothing
wrong with selling yourself Johnson
before you worry about scale like I'm
worried that you didn't put enough like
you could like one thing that people
don't realize is there's a lot of
different ways to flip meaning you want
to books that homie resi resells made a
lot of money because you just went all
macro you just bought every book and
just made the ARB and then decided what
to do with the both books every single
person watching this right now can go to
Marshalls buy sneakers flip them on
Amazon and make money every single one
now some people are happy with $2,000
for 11 hours of work this week others
aren't you've got to figure out if
reselling fits your ambition or if you
need to be doing something altogether
different
what reselling is really good for in my
opinion is for people that want to make
under a hundred thousand a year with the
19 hours a week that they waste that's
set if you get really good and you're
lucky I was given that advice because
that mean was push me like I got nothing
so I was doing that I said dollar store
I was like 6 bucks buy six choch goes
make 11 back go back by 11 11 cha chose
19 back go buy 19 shots cos $43 back
when I hear two kids got 2000 of start
you can make yeah that's a that's a
$10,000 sneaker flip from Marshalls I
wonder what he wants like what the world
number that's a good goal for you and
what do you want what would make you
happy
well the time scale yeah but like so
okay let's go there what's your time
work bro what's your time worth per hour
Jonathan um like this last week
no no you've got this thought in your
mind of my time is so [ __ ] valuable
then I've got to make it efficient in
your mind what is the money you want to
make per hour well I don't have the time
was per hour I just have a goal for like
about 15 years from now what's the goal
is he using it um couple hundred million
up one good man okay probably not like
the I have an actual
number 440 but that's because miles
banishing figure of mind to go to Mars
yeah and then dude then like so like so
you're you're telling me your ultimate
ambition is to go to Mars
not the four hundred forty million right
but I want money to build look make sure
I found three hundred much needed to pay
your husband to go to my other mother
but why Gary help invited yet you got
someone to go tomorrow
I like him right a bit no I'm super
happy Jonathan I think you should
document you should you should literally
document your journey to Mars bro how
long is it alright man good luck let's
move on I'm here listen I I think that
would listen that's an interest I've
never heard that before she's selling
books
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you